Donald Trump hilariously said yesterday
that the difference between him and
Nixon is that Nixon left and Trump is
not going to leave and this is hilarious
because it implies that the difference
is not that Nixon did bad things and
Trump didn't it implies that the
difference is not that Nixon committed
crime crimes and Donald Trump didn't if
you have some sense of Watergate you
probably have realized by now that the
current Trump situation is actually
worse than Watergate in many ways Trump
and Nixon both fired people to try to
stop investigations into them that's
obstruction both Nixon and Trump dangled
pardons often through attorneys in front
of people in different ways and
otherwise try to influence witnesses to
lie the Moller report just like the
Watergate roadmap outlines the
wrongdoing by Trump as the other
document did with Richard Nixon but
there's a huge way in which Trump 2019
is worse than Nixon 1974 which is that
in 1974 Republicans eventually came
around and realized that Nixon had to go
2019 Republicans are way more partisan
and amoral than Republicans in 1974 and
it makes the entire situation far worse
than 1974 because we have an entire
party with a few exceptions very few
that's not going to hold Donald Trump
accountable so then in comes Trump more
and more talk of impeachment more and
more demand for an impeachment inquiry
in the House of Representatives and
yesterday Trump decides it's time to
draw a line draw a distinction between
him and Nixon in 74 who of course
resigned before Republicans and
Democrats could impeach him which they
were going to and Trump yesterday says
after repeating the normal no collusion
no obstruction stuff that the difference
between him and Nixon is that Nixon
eventually left and Donald Trump will
not leave does not leave check it out
you can't beat somebody when there's
never been anything done wrong we we
have a no collusion
we have no anything there's no
obstruction there's no
illusion there's no anything when you
look at past impeachments weather was
President Clinton or I guess
President Nixon never got there he left
I don't leave there's a big difference I
don't leave we did nothing wrong except
create the greatest economy in the
history of our country now I get it
Trump's not saying he did something
wrong he's if anything implying Nixon
did nothing wrong either but left anyway
because of pressure and Trump having
done nothing wrong as far as he's
concerned is not going to leave that
being said I agree the main differences
between Nixon and Trump are that number
one Nixon was much smarter and that
Nixon eventually left whereas Trump's
ego and narcissism will probably prevent
him from ever choosing to leave meaning
it's going to be up to us to remove him
which most efficiently will happen
seventeen months from now less than
seventeen months from now in November of
2020 when we have that election and can
vote him out because even though Trump
is insisting on no collusion no
obstruction there's this hint of truth
in what Donald Trump says Nixon got
caught
Nixon accepted responsibility I won't
Donald Trump is saying now there is one
other interpretation here Trump has this
projection tendency where he often
blames the other for doing what he did
or he says the opposite of what he's
actually Singh thinking so lots of
examples of Trump saying he has full
confidence in a particular staffers work
and then that staffer is fired
a week later many examples of that so
the other interpretation here is that
Trump is in a sense projecting by even
bringing up the idea that Nixon left and
I won't leave it's a signal that Trump
is actually starting to think about
leaving
I don't know and by the way in July of
1973 Nixon also said that he wasn't
going to leave in the New York Times
check this out from July 20th 1973 a
report President Nixon emerged from the
hospital today pale but combative and
immediately denounced suggestions that
he resign as just plain poppycock
interpreting for the vocabulary of the
time this is what Donald Trump is saying
today I'm not going to go Nixon of
course eventually did I
maybe Donald Trump will as well it's
another criminal president talking about
how he would never resign until Nixon
actually resigned if you're Trump and so
far you've gotten away with everything
it does make sense to just say I'm not
leaving period if and until something
changes and that's up to us the the best
path forward I've outlined it now for
several weeks an impeachment inquiry
should immediately start in the House of
Representatives the point of it is not
to actually removed from because it
won't we're not going to get Republicans
between now and November of 2020 to
remove Donald Trump via impeachment the
point of the impeachment inquiry is to
damage Trump by exposing the content of
the Moller report to turn voters against
Donald Trump so that they will
ultimately vote him out in November of
2020 period that is the best path
forward if you disagree let me know I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow us
both and let me know what you think
today's sponsor is Skillshare and I'm
excited to tell you that everybody in
our audience is getting two entire
months of free access to Skillshare when
you click the link underneath this video
skill shares the site that offers over
25,000 online courses on almost any
topic you can imagine cooking meditation
photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription
they're super affordable at less than
ten bucks a month get better at whatever
it is that you're passionate about or
discover something brand new that you
didn't even know that you would love and
join skill shares other 7 million users
by clicking the link underneath this
video
[Music]